Костянтину 44 роки, майже 19 із них він пропрацював на шахті.
Щодня він одягає спецодяг і спускається в лаву -
місце, де видобувають вугілля.
Фізично важко в лаві працювати.
Секції перетягувати, підсилювачі ставити. І звичка, і взагалі - а що?
Так заробляємо, доводиться.
Шахтоуправління "Покровське" - одне з небагатьох вугільних підприємств,
які досі працюють на Донеччині.
Попри те, що до фронту менш як 50 кілометрів.
Це місце роботи для восьми тисяч людей.
Костянтин зізнається, що колись мріяв про інше.
Мрія у мене була - стати далекобійником.
Так вийшло просто, що були важкі часи, вивчився, потім складно з грошима було.
Вийшло, що влаштувався на це підприємство.
Замість безкрайніх автобанів - підземна залізниця.
Колії, що простягаються на 20 кілометрів і з'єднують між собою стовбури шахти.
Ми перебуваємо на глибині 593 метри в одному з ключових
транспортних вузлів шахти. Для гірників, які тут працюють,
це надійне укриття від бойових дій, які відбуваються
зовсім недалеко від Покровська.
Тут видобувають високоякісне коксівне вугілля.
З нього роблять паливо для металургійних комбінатів.
Раніше це були маріупольські заводи - "Азовсталь"
та комбінат імені Ілліча.
Нині - здебільшого підприємства Східної Європи.
Шахта приносить валютні надходження.
У нас іде повноцінна, повномасштабна війна, тому зараз будь-які сценарії
можна уявляти, але ми продовжуємо працювати.
Ми зробили бомбосховище, ми регулярно стикаємось з повним блекаутом,
відключенням електропостачання.
Під землею залишаються шахтарі, там близько тисячі людей.
Ми поставили потужні генератори, які ми підіймаємо
на поверхню людей, коли ці блекаути настають.
Ми підготувалися до всіх цих можливих негараздів, з якими вже стикнулися.
Хоча робота під землею ніколи не була безпечною, думками гірники - на поверхні,
адже війна створює нові ризики.
Думаємо постійно про це.
Вдома сім'я, переживаєш про це, щоб нічого не сталося,
щоб не було таких… неприємностей.
Наприкінці лютого Костянтин залишився без житла -
його будинок обстріляла російська армія.
Була на четвертому поверсі моя квартира.
Прожив тут 44 роки. І все, і в один прекрасний момент - не стало.
Під час прильоту Костянтина, його дружини і двох дітей не було вдома.
Зі зруйнованої квартири чоловік встиг врятувати дещо з меблів
і дитячий велотренажер.
Я просто не політик. Я не знаю, як воно там, що...
Чому воно так почалося? Що вони не поділили? Територію, так?
Вони вважають, що це їхня територія. Якщо ми все життя прожили тут, в Україні,
як воно може вважатися Росією? Я не розумію цього.
Коротше, життя починається знову. У мене зараз немає нічого,
от хіба машина - у чому я можу на цей момент жити, і все.
Дякувати Богу, що так. Пустили люди пожити.
А так, ось у мене було - нема нічого.
У ще однієї співробітниці шахти - Олени - інша історія.
Вона працювала на "Азовсталі" в Маріуполі.
Це якраз моя остання зміна була - 24 лютого.
Це якраз я була вночі. Ми почули, що воно бахнуло.
Всі думали, що це кран. А потім, коли з бані туди прийшли,
нам кажуть, що почалася війна.
Олена з чоловіком і двома дітьми пішки виходили з Маріуполя,
щоб дістатися до підконтрольної Україні території.
У Покровську жінка влаштувалася працювати на вентиляторі шахти.
Утім мріє повернутися додому, в Маріуполь.
Я весь час спостерігаю, у нас чат є. І досі всі, і керівництво,
всі спілкуються, всі сподіваються, що його відбудують.
У мене діти тут не хочуть. Додому і все їм треба.
Після повномасштабного вторгнення промисловість Донеччини
практично зупинилася, кажуть в Донецькій ОВА.
Усі металургійні підприємства опинилися в окупації
або на лінії зіткнення. Шахти у Вугледарі зупинилися,
у Торецьку - перебувають під постійними обстрілами,
їм загрожує затоплення. За перші три місяці цього року
видобуток вугілля на Донеччині скоротився вполовину,
порівняно з таким самим періодом торік.
У відносно безпечному Покровську теж відчувається подих війни.
Є прильоти і в місті, і на шахті - були влучання в залізницю.
Та покладів вугілля вистачить ще надовго.
Тож шахта продовжить роботу.
Шахта не може працювати ситуативно - сьогодні відпрацювали і все.
Шахта працює, ось показую: ця ділянка працює, а ми вже готуємо наступну.
Так само ми працюємо на перспективу розвитку 2024 року і 2025.
Головна проблема на підприємстві - брак працівників.
Чверть персоналу виїхали до більш безпечних місць.
Та Костянтин і ще сотні шахтарів знову й знову спускатимуться у забій.
Виїжджаєш на свіже повітря - якось і настрій кращий.
Просто вже, коли в бані скупався, наче іншою людиною стаєш.
Весело вже. У шахті ти інша людина. Спускаєшся - ну, робота є робота.
Війна ставить шахтарів перед новим випробуванням:
щоразу, піднімаючись з-під землі,
вони не знають, що чекатиме на них на поверхні.